Avengers: Infinity War is one of Marvel's
most intense and emotional movies ever with
an ending that's loaded with consequences
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'm breaking down the shocking
ending to Avengers: Infinity War as well as
explaining some easter eggs and theories and
what they mean for Avengers 4.
Don't forget my Avengers Funko Pop giveaway
is running, so make sure you're a subscriber
and leave me a comment about the movie for
a chance to win.
Obviously, spoilers ahead if you haven't seen
the movie.
Let's start with the Snap.
Yes, this was when the horrifying moment teased
by Gamora towards the start of the film came
true.
After Thanos snapped his fingers in the gauntlet,
around half of our heroes disintegrated one-by-one
into ash, like a slow-motion nightmare.
Comic book fans will recognise this as the
iconic snap moment from the Infinity Gauntlet
comics where the Mad Titan snapped his fingers
and half the universe, including half the
Marvel superheroes, disappeared.
It's a shocking moment because, as an audience
when we watch a typical superhero or action
movie, we often expect the hero to come in
at the final moment and save the day with
a glorious act of heroism.
It was incredibly powerful to watch each hero
make a final stand against the Mad Titan.
And then to see Thanos just swat each one
aside like they were nothing, even Captain
America who was the last hero standing between
Thanos getting to Wanda and Vision.
It was gut-wrenching to then see Wanda end
Vision before Thanos brought him back and
killed him again but this time with appalling
brutality as he ripped out the Mind Stone.
And despite Thor having warned Thanos at the
start that he'd die for what he'd done to
the Asgardians, even Thor's magnificent entrance
and blow to Thanos's chest with Stormbreaker
wasn't enough.
The ending we expect as an audience is pretty
much overturned as basically the Avengers
lose to the very big bad.
And if you look back at previous MCU movies,
for example, Age of Ultron, you can see how
this moment was foreshadowed.
"We're the Avengers."
"We can bust arms dealers all the livelong
day, but that up there, that's...
That's the endgame."
"How were you guys planning on beating that?"
"Together."
"We'll lose."
"Then we'll do that together, too."
So, although Cap and Tony are still separated
geographically at the end of Infinity War,
in a way, they did both fight Thanos together;
one in Wakanda and the other on Titan.
But to truly defeat Thanos in Avengers 4 Tony
and Cap are going to have to bring some balance
back to their own relationship.
And before the credits roll, the movie ends
with a scene of Thanos looking out over a
beautiful, green and fertile land.
On the surface it looks like he's won, he's
achieved balance in the universe and he's
finally stopping to rest and, as he said,
'watch the sun rise on a grateful universe'.
In fact, the way Thanos talks about wanting
time-out after he's finished his plan in the
movie has shades of how he goes on to live
a quiet life as 'Farmer Thanos' in the comics.
And the film's closing scene also mirrors
this image at the end of the Infinity Gauntlet
comics.
But even though Thanos smiles to himself in
the movie, I think there's a lot more to this
ending that's hidden beneath the surface.
For a start, let's remember that the original
Avengers are still alive and I think that
what Tony Stark said to Loki in the first
Avengers movie is going to be important for
what happens next.
"There is no version of this where you come
out on top."
"Maybe your army comes and maybe it's too
much for us, but it's all on you."
"Because if we can't protect the Earth, you
can be damn well sure we'll avenge it."
I suspect that means in Avengers 4, the heroes
that have survived will become literal Avengers.
They'll be angry and driven to figure out
how to find and take revenge on Thanos for
everyone he's taken away from them.
And, as Thor said in this movie, 'rage, revenge,
anger, loss, and regret [are] all tremendous
motivators.'
And I wonder if a possible title for the next
team-up movie could therefore be Avengers
Reassembled.
From Marvel Studios' point of view, it also
means the actors whose contracts are expiring,
like Robert Downey Jr and Chris Evans, can
go out with a really big bang, perhaps even
sacrificing themselves to bring back those
who disappeared.
"You hope for the best and make do with what
you get.
I got a great team."
"Nothing lasts forever."
And because the snap means a lot of characters
have vanished, it leaves room for characters
like Hawkeye, Ant-Man and Wasp who didn't
get a part in Infinity War to come in for
a significant role in Avengers 4.
On top of this, there are some very important
moments in Infinity War where clues were dropped
on how the Avengers will be able to climb
out of this desperate situation.
First of all, think back to that moment when
Doctor Strange went forward in time and checked
more than 14 million possibilities for an
outcome in which the Avengers won.
Strange told Tony that there was just one
scenario in which that happened.
Later, when the fight against Thanos went
south and the Mad Titan was about to kill
Iron Man, Doctor Strange made a bargain with
Thanos to trade the Time Stone for Tony's
life.
But remember, earlier on the Q-ship, Strange
had been adamant that, if it came to saving
them or the Time Stone, he would not hesitate
to let Tony or Peter Parker die.
So, it's clear that Strange's action of trading
Tony's life for the Time Stone was a very
deliberate decision by the Sorcerer Supreme.
Notice how Strange also said "we're in the
endgame now" after he handed the stone over,
which is an echo of Tony's words in Age of
Ultron about his vision.
Which means that Strange knew that giving
the Time Stone to Thanos was the only scenario
in which Thanos could be defeated.
This was emphasised when, just before fading
away, Strange told Tony there was no other
way, a big hint and hopefully a clue that
Tony Stark will pick up on that giving up
the Time Stone to Thanos will, in time, lead
to the Mad Titan's defeat.
That future timeline that Doctor Strange foresaw
needed Thanos to get all six Infinity Stones
and for Tony Stark to remain alive.
By the way, apparently, Benedict Cumberbatch,
who plays Doctor Strange, was one of the few
cast who got to read the full Infinity War
script and he's said it was because his character
had to understand the context of all the events,
and that Doctor Strange's responsibility is
to protect the Multiverse and hold it together.
I think that in Avengers 4, the Avengers will
need to figure out Thanos's true weakness
which we had hints of in Infinity War.
For example, there was the small cut that
Iron Man landed on Thanos's face during the
fight on Titan, as well as Thanos's taunt
to Thor that he should have gone for his head
with Stormbreaker.
And intriguingly, after the snap, when Thanos
reappeared, the Infinity Gauntlet seemed to
have burned up or been damaged in some way
suggesting another possible weakness there.
One vital theme which runs throughout Infinity
War and is necessary to really understand
the story is that the film is all about the
cost of being a hero.
"The theme of the movie is about what is the
cost to be a hero in a complicated world."
"And does the cost ... you know ... is the
value of doing what's right outweigh the he
cost?"
This is a thread woven through a number of
MCU movies, for example, Captain America:
Civil War where the collateral damage from
the Avengers' activities became a global issue
that led to the Sokovia Accords as a way to
attempt to regulate the superhero team's activities.
But, by the end of Infinity War, we can see
that the cost for each of our favourite heroes
has become truly personal.
Peter Parker dying in Tony Starks's arms was
an extremely emotional moment for both the
audience and, of course, Tony who mentored
the budding superhero.
Remember what Tony said to Spidey after what
happened with the ferry in Homecoming?
"What if somebody had died tonight?
Different story, right?
"Cause that's on you.
And if you died, I feel like that's on me.
I don't need that on my conscience."
Tony did try to stop Peter joining this mission
as he knew the journey to Titan was too dangerous
for the friendly neighbourhood Spider-Man.
In fact, Tony's words that, 'this isn't a
school trip, it's a one-way ticket', turned
out to be a heart-breaking bit of foreshadowing.
And when everyone on Titan starts disintegrating
in front of Iron Man, I couldn't help but
think of Tony's vision and his interpretation
of that vision in Age of Ultron.
"I wasn't tricked, I was shown.
It wasn't a nightmare, it was my legacy.
The end of the path I started us on."
"I watched my friends die.
You'd think that'd be as bad as it gets, right?"
"Nope.
Wasn't the worst part."
"The worst part is that you didn't."
For Steve Rogers, our Captain America, watching
his life-long friend Bucky, who he fought
so hard to bring back from being brainwashed
by HYDRA, just evaporate into dust must have
been devastating.
After all, they always had each other's backs.
"I'm with you till the end of the line pal."
"I'm not gonna fight you."
"You're my friend."
"Cos I'm with you till the end of the line."
Earlier in the film, Scarlet Witch told Vision
that taking his life to destroy the Mind Stone
was too high a price, but he told her that
she was the only one who had the power to
pay it.
And at the end, not only did she have to sacrifice
her lover by blasting the Mind Stone out of
his forehead to obliterate it, but she then
had to witness Thanos reverse her actions
before murdering Vision in a most horrible
way.
And ultimately, she was snapped away herself.
By the way, when we see the colour drain from
Vision as Thanos takes the Mind Stone from
him, it echoes his look in the comics during
his time with the West Coast Avengers.
Like Vision, Gamora too was willing to sacrifice
her own life in an effort to stop Thanos.
And, similar to Scarlet Witch, Star-Lord made
the awful decision to take the life of Gamora,
the woman he loved, as he'd promised her he
would; though Thanos, of course, used the
Reality Stone to turn Quill's blaster into
bubbles.
On top of that, Gamora also had to make the
terrible choice between ending her sister
Nebula's torture at the hands of Thanos and
giving the Mad Titan exactly what he wanted:
the location of the Soul Stone.
Loki faced the same decision and, after saving
his brother, later paid the ultimate price
for trying to do the right thing rather than
allying himself with the Mad Titan.
The God of Mischief has had heroic moments
in previous films such as saving his brother
and Jane Foster from the Dark Elves in Thor:
The Dark World, but ultimately he used that
moment for his own gain to take the throne.
But that was certainly not the case this time.
Groot gave up one of his arms both to save
Thor and in service of creating what the Asgardian
god called his Thanos-killing weapon, Stormbreaker.
And Thor, who's lost his brother, parents,
friends, and home over the years, was also
willing to risk his own life as he attempted
to start the forges on Nidavellir.
For Black Panther, the cost of opening up
Wakanda to the world turned out to be considerable
as his country and his people were at the
very centre of Earth's battle against Thanos
and so many Wakandans, including himself,
lost their lives.
Ultimately, each of our heroes did pay the
price, and it was certainly a hard and heavy
one.
In a way, you could say this personal cost
that each character paid is what defines them
as a true hero.
But even when they did what was necessary
for the greater good, often at huge personal
cost, at this point, it was seemingly all
for nothing; they gave everything yet in the
end were still defeated.
But as Steve Rogers said to Tony Stark in
Civil War, 'if someone dies on our watch,
we don't give up.'
And to quote Nick Fury in the first Avengers
movie:
"Until such time as the world ends, we will
continue as if it spins on."
As for the film's villain, Thanos, who saw
himself as the hero of the story and the only
one willing to do what was vital for the universe,
even he had to pay a price by sacrificing
the daughter he loved.
Now, there's another interesting moment where
Thanos visits a mystery orangey-red world.
My current theory is that this is connected
with the Infinity Stones and I'll talk more
about that in a separate video about how the
Soul Stone works.
I'll link it here as soon as it's ready.
We've talked a lot about how Infinity War
is not your typical Marvel movie and that
even carried over into how the credits played
out.
Normally, there's a set of fancy credits immediately
after the last scene, but Infinity War instead
went for a simple white text on black to reflect
the sombre note the film ends on.
It was a rather creative choice when the Avengers:
Infinity War title that came on at the usual
mid-credits moment faded into dust, leaving
us with no mid-credits scene.
But, of course, there was still one crucial
post-credits scene that came right at the
end after all the credits rolled.
In that scene, we see the effects of the snap
rippling around the world, in this case New
York with Nick Fury and Maria Hill.
And there's also a very cool Captain Marvel
tease.
I've already done a full breakdown and explanation
of everything in that scene in my post-credits
video which you can watch by tapping right
up here, or clicking the link in the video
description below.
So, what did you think about the shocking
end of Infinity War?
And how do you think our heroes will defeat
Thanos in Avengers 4?
Let me know below and make sure you're subscribed
for my Avengers Funko Pop giveaway!
Tap here for all my latest Infinity War and
Marvel videos including post-credit breakdowns,
interviews, and Avengers 4 theories!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!